(dramatic piano music)
- Today we're exploring the deep ocean
and its rarely seen creatures.
My grandfather Jacques Cousteau
was always looking to chronicle
the wonders of the ocean,
and the giant isopod is
one of the most fascinating
and strange-looking.
These crustaceans live thousands of feet
beneath the ocean's surface,
typically between 500 and 7,000 feet deep.
They can grow up to two feet long,
but this one's just a baby.
The reason they're so big
is due to something--
- [Man With Hat] Sorry.
- Is due to something
called sea gigantism.
We don't know why this happens.
It might be due to deep ocean pressure,
or to scarcity of food resources.
Either way, these guys are huge.
They're carnivores and they
have four sets of jaws,
but can go for years without eating.
Are you guys eating?
You barely lasted an hour.
One isopod in captivity in Japan
survived five years without eating.
OK, give me a chip.
(dramatic instrumental music)